we have now passed 1 million reported
cases of the virus nationwide that's
about a third of the total reported
globally so that means more than one in
every 330 Americans has now tested
positive in Brooklyn members of the
Hasidic Jewish community defied social
distancing orders to hold a funeral
procession for a rabbi who had
reportedly died from the corona virus
police had to move in to break it up
Anthony that incident that incident
highlights potential tensions about
what's safe in areas like Florida where
restrictions are slowly being lifted
Manuel Bojorquez is in Miami many the
state just reported its highest daily
death toll so far but we understand
today the governor is still expected to
announce plans to reopen
that's right Anthony governor Ron de
santis has indicated that phase 1 of the
state's reopening plan would be a quote
small step today some public outdoor
spaces will begin to reopen in two of
the state's largest and hardest hit
counties with social distancing rules in
place but as you mentioned with
confirmed cases and deaths still rising
here some wonder whether it's too soon
until I feel by following the science
that Mitch Kaplan's books may be
collecting dust but the owner of seven
community bookstores in Florida says
he's not quite ready to let customers
back in better pay attention and know
what which could be what in your view
get sick could be that a customer gets
sick it could be Florida is among the
latest states to announce its lifting
parts of its lockdown effective May 1st
restaurants fitness centers retail
stores and enclosed malls may reopen at
50% of normal operating capacity Iowa
Governor Kim Reynolds announced
businesses in 77 of Iowa's 99 counties
could operate with limits despite the
statewide number of confirmed cases
increasing by around 7
five percent in a week in New York
Tuesday Governor Andrew Cuomo announced
the creation of an advisory board to
help guide the state's reopening
strategy the move comes as some
communities continue to push back
against stay-at-home orders a funeral
for a Hasidic rabbi in Brooklyn prompted
a forceful response from police it's one
of several times over the past month
community members have gathered
despite being particularly hard-hit by
the outbreak I think we might want to
consider getting that school year moved
up a little bit in California governor
Gavin Newsom suggested schools there
could reopen as early as July
even though cases and deaths have
continued to rise across the state some
educators have expressed concerns on how
classrooms would operate with social
distancing limitations but there are
parents like Amber Williams who say
they're supportive of reopening schools
this summer that was my hope is that
they would start the next school year
earlier but what that looks like
I don't know Florida's governor said
Tuesday he believes much of the virus
spread came from places like New York
but Miami is also a popular destination
with travelers from Brazil and other
parts of Latin America which are seeing
their own outbreaks the governor said he
believes the airlines should be testing
passengers before allowing them to
travel Tony no easy decisions here many
thank you very much